by the way if this if this story is real
if this story is real and he's saying
it's real what do you mean it's done
and blinking you're texting it how do
you process that whole concept of 10
minutes after
the explosion happened she texts blink
and saying it's done that's very
confusing
how do you process it down I think
there's a chess game that's played in
the international Arena that is beyond
the narratives that that we see
um and something that that he just
brought up like about the natural gas
United States
um you know where Canada gets its
natural gas from the United States you
know how much natural gas they get from
the United States all of it you know so
we are we are OPEC to Canada national
natural gas and so when you look at the
reason I bring that up that's not a
stray statistic if you really step back
and look at the chess game that is the
world energy Market it's not as simple
as as well OPEC is a bunch of people
that turn the spigot on turn the spigot
off raise the price up or not listen to
what he was just saying he when he was
talking about it uh the prices he said
Brent there's three crude bases that
that are meaningful the United States
one is Middle East light Suite then
there's Brent or North Sea as it's
called and then there's also North
Dakota and a thing they call WTI West
Texas intermediate which comes out of
Permian Basin there's all of these
markets of fuel that are everywhere and
when you step back the the geopolitical
forces that are behind this are so much
different than we see at the average
level it would not surprise me that in
the chess game of Putin that what
basically what we would World War II
speaking here the Allies did was to say
you know what we're going to hit the
pipeline because it's going to cause
this this this this this this and this
and there you go and you know in the
meantime you know the president speaks
out the other side of his mouth because
if you don't think we knew about that or
winked at it you don't understand the
power of the United States on a military
stage around the world if you don't
think we winked at that number one and
then two days later what is Biden doing
I'm gonna put a tax on there for this
windfall tax on all these oil companies
really why don't you backtrack some of
the political donations of the American
Energy Consortium and I think it's just
a bigger chess game than people
understand but you know who knows the
truth about this like there's probably
only one person likely I mean that
actually knows the truth and that's
Putin either he ordered this or he
didn't
so if he ordered it he knows what's
going on but if he didn't give this
order he knows that there's some some
stuff foul stuff that somebody smells in
Denmark right something rotten in
Denmark some singers rotten yeah so
ultimately he knows what's going on here
I mean who know I don't know if there's
been any did Paul Sankey basically say
he believes that this was
the hands of the British via America via
the EU what have you is that what he
kind of said so I believe it I believe
it because it helps Baltic and it helps
it helps neutralize Putin because now
Putin has to do two things one you know
whose pipeline is that
um
who owns Nordstrom
Russia Russians and the Germans yeah
what did we just do
we turned off the cash register on
Nordstrom
they're not delivering and so they're
not getting paid
meanwhile the Baltic pipeline is on so
I'm saying you got to step back and look
at this like in three dimensions it's
not hard but it takes time right and
this is Putin's Soul Big Money Maker
like what's the famous phrase about
Russia that Russia is really just a gas
station masquerading as a country
so if you cut off their
money supply oil supply
you know there goes their revenue so who
knows what actually is happening here
but it would be a
a gangster ass move by the the British
if that's exactly what happened so I'm
listening to this and it's just making
me curious about you know the midterms
are going to come and go and then the
focus is going to shift very quickly to
the presidential election and I'm just
curious how much of that presidential
election
how much do voters care about these very
specific issues we're talking about
about oil supply which comes down to
drilling which the Biden Administration
has stood against in numerous instances
how much do they care about lifting
regulations on the refineries which
would then increase the capacity of
those refineries and how much do they
care about where does the voting public
stand on involvement in this foreign
policy stuff liberals you know for a
long time claim to be
non-interventionists now I see them all
with Ukrainian flags all over there you
know bios and they're wanting us to give
more Aid to Ukraine which in turn is
deepening our involvement in that whole
situation I see mostly conservatives
saying get out this is none of our
business you know becoming more
non-interventionist which is why by the
way a guy like Trump won in the in his
election to begin with because he was
relatively non-interventionist and
conservatives are more
non-interventionist than people realize
because when they think of conservatives
they think of you know the Liz Chinese
and the on McCain's and that's not
reflective of what the conservative
voter looks like in large part but I'm
just curious how much this is going to
come into play because some of it is
directly related to economy it's
directly related to economy and security
which are the two issues that we've
really been talking about throughout
this whole podcast so maybe this all
comes front and center and rather than
having a largely domestic policy
conversation it becomes much more of a
foreign policy conversation for for
those that are going to be running for
the next time around what people don't
understand is as I've felt that there is
a far left agenda that really just wants
to neutralize the United States and to
bring upon this you know this liberal
World equality and globalism pure and so
when you put pipelines across the
Midwest United States which they
canceled when you and by the way
everybody he's on the news about the
drilling permits right nobody sees
anything anything about the refinery
permits it doesn't matter how much oil
you have if you can't heat it up and
turn it into Aviation gas kerosene
Diesel and gasoline and nylon so if you
can't if you can't refine it then you
can't do all these things and if you
take a look at the reality of what's up
there do you remember when North Dakota
had a real economic boom it's when the
Saudis artificially kept the price of
oil too high and what happened was if
that's everybody was moving to North
Dakota because if the price of a barrel
was that high then that's the price they
have to work with to get the heat into
the Earth to extract the Shale oil when
the price comes back down and I think it
was sixty dollars that if if a crude on
a national basis I mean a global basis
goes below 60 Suddenly It's not
economically viable to pull Shale oil so
what you do is you pause and I can turn
it back on when the prices are the other
side is Anwar what's up in Alaska if if
we were to drill and put pipelines in
you and this will shock you it is five
to seven years the full energy
Independence and that's right and we
would have more clout than Venezuela and
UAE put together on a global stage to
export crude who and by the way what
happens then the power and elevation and
stature of the United States as a and
the potential to be a bully you know
goes up and all the globalists are like
we can't have that happen so they don't
want drilling they don't want permitting
and they don't want pipelines this is a
big chess game and this is all what's
going there and I think it's
you know this is the part that that
drives me really well Jed back to your
uh initial question like how much does
the American voter care about these
essentially nuanced discussions about
oil and and Shale and burning no zero
they care about the price at the pump
that's it like I just learned something
from bizdoc and part of me is like oh
that's very interesting all of the above
can bring your price to the pump too
yeah nobody cares it's my point they
care about 175. no they don't care about
care about the price at the pump they
don't care well you gotta understand
that Anwar and when you heat it up and
they're like dude what are you talking
about like just is gas eight dollars a
gallon or is it three dollars a gallon
that's all I care about and that's the
American voter so I think though that
the that there is a growing part of the
population of the American voter that
cares about the idea that I talk about
all the time that the current
destruction is intentional and we
shifted that over from when we talk
about the system The Matrix whatever you
want to call it we talk about the
coveted agenda and that was largely
lockdowns that was mandates that was the
way that Society was crippled by the
reaction to covid not covet itself and
now that has changed and shifted over by
the globalists of the world hi Bill
Gates if you're watching to The Climate
agenda and now that climate agenda is
going to be first and foremost as a
means to [ __ ] society and that's
what's going to hit these refineries
that's what's going to hit prevent
drilling you know what you're talking
about about Anwar I researched that
extensively when I first got into
politics because that was the stuff that
Sarah Palin was talking about they dove
in and went right after her primarily
because she was an expert on energy
Independence had been working on that
for years and she was deeply threatening
to the system as a result of that and
her expertise in that particular area so
I think this is the new topic that does
become relevant this climate agenda
because it's being utilized by the folks
at the top to [ __ ] society and I
think that because these prices do
affect their everyday life do a fact
what they're paying at the pump do
affect you know say do affect National
Security do affect then the safety of
themselves and their families I think
that if you can make that argument
tangible to people and it's not
something happening out there in the
world it's something happening right
here in their hands in their home in
their backyard I do think people will be
very very plugged into that and I would
advocate for a republican candidate
whoever it is Ron DeSantis Donald Trump
whoever it may be to zero in on that
climate agenda because that is going to
be the biggest Force for Destruction
that the left is going to utilize to
criminal Society so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]